[MUSIC PLAYING]
SVETOSLAV GANOV: So I'd like
to share a little bit how
I got here today.
I had to set up
an alarm at 5:30.
I had to snooze it several
times before I woke up.
After that, I took
my dog for a walk.
And I like to listen to
some music while I do this.
Huge trance fan, by the way.
After I finished
walking my dog, I
had to check my
calendar so I know
exactly where I need to be so
I don't go on the wrong stage.
And lastly, I had to
check my bus schedule.
And I realized I was late.
So I ran real fast
and I made it.
It's funny-- my wife
still thinks I'm a runner.
And actually I am.
I run every day
to catch the bus.
[LAUGHTER]
CHARMAINE D'SILVA: And
good morning, everyone.
My name is Charmaine
D'Silva, and I'm
a product manager on Android.
Like Svet, I spend my
days driving to meetings.
Some days I get to
travel to meet all of you
and find my way to new cities.
And after all the
excitement of my days,
I get to say good
night to my boys
before I end my day with
my favorite TV shows.
Of course, my favorite TV
shows have dragons these days.
Now, pausing to think
about both our stories,
you must have guessed
by now that all of this
was achieved on our smartphones.
But our stories are
in no way unique.
Every day, billions of
people around the world
use the applications
that you've built
to connect with people
around the world
and do incredible things.
However, our users tell us that
they want more transparency
and control over their data.
They expect Android
as a platform
to give them tools for that
transparency and control.
This responsibility to
our users is something
that you've all
taken very seriously.
And that's why we're here today.
We're here to talk to you
about the new privacy features
in Android Q and how
you can leverage them
to build privacy-forward apps.
SVETOSLAV GANOV: Over the
years, Android has matured.
We've added a wide
range of features
to protect our users, like
file-based encryption,
runtime permissions,
lockdown mode, Google Play
Protect, and many more.
On Android, we embrace
privacy as a way to innovate.
And Android has always
been designed with security
and privacy at its core.
In Android Q, we
wanted to go further.
We added almost 50
features related
to privacy and security.
So these features are designed
to provide more protection,
user control, and transparency.
To develop these features,
we worked very closely
with many of you.
We shared our ideas, our
designs, our prototypes.
We heard your feedback
and we embedded this back
into our products.
We couldn't have done
this without you.
So thank you all so much.
CHARMAINE D'SILVA:
As Svet mentioned,
you've spent countless
of hours with us
through workshops, filing
bugs, and testing our betas,
helping us understand
the issues you face
and enabling us to
serve you better.
We will continue to
build apps that matter.
None of this could have been
possible without all of you
all.
Thank you all for your support.
SVETOSLAV GANOV: We're so
grateful to have developers
like you help us build
a better platform.
So now we want to help you
build privacy-forward apps that
delight your users.
CHARMAINE D'SILVA: Through
the rest of this journey,
we will share with
you best practices
and introduce you to the
new features in Android Q.
Let's get started.
SVETOSLAV GANOV: So
starting with permissions.
As you already
know, applications
run in their own sandboxes.
So your application
to access user data
needs to request
specific permissions.
In Android 6.0, we
introduced the concept
of front-end permissions.
This allows your application
at runtime to prompt the user
[INAUDIBLE] private data.
And the user can choose to
deny or approve the request.
CHARMAINE D'SILVA:
As Svet mentioned,
users have the ability to
approve or deny requests.
We're always curious
to understand
what users do with our devices.
When we survey our users to
understand why they actually
deny permission, these are
the top three reasons we see.
One, the app should not
need the permission.
Two, they expect the app to
still work without permission.
And three, they feel like they
can grant permission later.
All of this tells us one thing.
Users who deny permissions
do not understand the value
when the app is asking for it.
With this in mind,
let's talk about how
best to deal with permissions.
OK, step 1.
Determine if there
are alternate APIs
to give you the
data that you need.
If there are
alternate APIs, choose
to use them instead of
asking for permission.
Alternate APIs tend to be
narrow in scope, which makes
them a better privacy choice.
Let's go through a few examples.
Let's assume the app needs
to do SMS verification.
Instead of asking for the
SMS runtime permission,
you could instead use
the SMS retriever API.
SVETOSLAV GANOV:
SMS verification
is a common use case
for which developers
ask for the SMS permission.
Fortunately, Google
Play services
has dedicated API for
exactly this use case.
The entry point is the SMS
Retriever Client and domain
method is startSmsRetriever.
CHARMAINE D'SILVA:
Here's another example.
What if your app need to know
if the user was in a phone call?
Instead of asking for the
READ_PHONE_STATE permission,
you can instead call the Audio
Focus API to see call state.
SVETOSLAV GANOV: Detecting
whether the user is in a phone
call are common
reasons apps are asking
for the phone permission.
But there is a better way.
You can use the Audio Focus API.
If the user is currently
in a phone call,
you will not be able
to gain Audio Focus.
All you need to remember is to
use the audio manager compact
and request Audio Focus method.
CHARMAINE D'SILVA: Last example.
What if your app needed
access to external storage?
You do not necessarily
need to ask for the read
external storage permission.
You can instead leverage your
app's private app storage
or use a system file picker.
SVETOSLAV GANOV: Apps often
request the storage permission
without taking advantage
of their dedicated folder
on external storage, which does
not require holding the read
and write storage permission.
The way you get this
folder, you call
context.getExternalFilesDir.
Also, the system
provides ways for you
to bring trusted
system UI for the user
to pick a file or directory
so you can work with it.
The way can bring the
chooser UI is to fire
the ACTION_OPEN_DOCUMENT.
And the way to bring
the UI to pick a folder
is to fire the
ACTION_OPEN_DOCUMENT_TREE.
These are just a few
examples how you can use APIs
without asking for permissions
to provide better user
experience.
Please go to the Android
Developer website
to learn more.
CHARMAINE D'SILVA: OK.
So now you've done your
research and realize
there are no alternative
APIs to give you
the data that you need.
You're now at step two--
determining the scope
for the permission
and how you'd ask for it.
In speaking to many
developers like yourself,
you'll believe that you will get
higher acceptance rate if you
ask for permissions upfront.
However, when we poll our users,
we see that only 18% of users
accept every permission
of the device.
Most users make
deliberate choices.
SVETOSLAV GANOV: Now
that I think about it,
I'm one of those people that
always approves permissions.
But if I think a
little bit more,
I do it only if I
understand the use case
and there is an immediate
value for me as a user
if I grant a permission.
CHARMAINE D'SILVA:
And Svet's experience
is not unlike our users.
When we ask a user why they
choose to give an app access
or permission, the
top reason they say
is because they wanted to use
a specific feature off an app.
This tells us that they were
intentional with their choice.
Users are more likely to give
your app access to permission
if they understand the purpose
and the perceived benefits
feels logical.
Let's go through
examples of where
the benefit of the granted
permission is very clear.
SVETOSLAV GANOV: So, if
the context is clear,
ask for permission directly.
And this way users
will know exactly why
the permission is needed.
They have context and
there is an immediate value
for the user.
And there is a
higher probability
of the user granting the
permission to the application,
thus using your feature.
For example, if you're
in a chat application
and you want to share a photo,
and you click the Camera
button, the user
will not be surprised
if they're asked for
the camera permission.
And they'll probably grant you
the permission, because they
want to use your feature.
CHARMAINE D'SILVA:
So, in this scenario
that Svet ran you through, the
use case is pretty obvious.
But that's not always the case.
There are situations
where you need
to educate the user of
your feature benefit
before the runtime
prompt is shown.
It's better to present
the use case right
before the runtime prompt.
Here's an example from Nest
Home/Away Assist feature.
This dialog precedes the
location runtime prompt.
In Android P, this is what
the location runtime prompt
looks like.
The user choice is binary.
Users can choose to
either approve or deny
the location request.
If a user provides location
permission to an app,
the app can now access
location in the foreground
or in the background.
In Android Q, we're introducing
more granular controls
to the app.
Users can give
the app the choice
to have only foreground access
to the location or foreground
and background
access to location.
As an app developer, only
ask for background app access
if you only have a
clear need for it.
SVETOSLAV GANOV: Now that
the location permission
can be requested while in
access and all the time,
you need to choose the
right scope that best
fits your feature.
Our recommendation
is whenever possible,
use while in use location.
The way you ask for while in use
location is exactly the same.
You ask for location, as always.
You ask for the coarse or
fine location permission.
However, if you want to access
location in the background,
you need to add an additional
modifier permission called
access background location.
So this permission
needs to be combined
with the existing fine and
coarse location permissions.
And this is a signal to the
platform to show UI to the user
where they have choices between
while in use, all the time,
and deny the request.
Scope is also
relevant to storage.
In Android Q, we add in the
concept of scope storage.
Scope storage provides better
application data isolation
and also protects
the collections
of videos and audio.
Later today, we have another
talk which goes in details.
And please attend that.
CHARMAINE D'SILVA: OK.
So now at this point,
you've got your app's
get runtime permissions.
You now have a responsibility
to use the data.
Step three, ensure users are not
surprised with your data usage.
Here are some best practices.
One, collect only the
data that you need.
Two, only share the data once
you get explicit user consent.
Three, if you're transferring
data off the device,
ensure that it is
encrypted and secure.
Four, only keep data for
as long as you need it.
By following these
best practices,
your users will feel
more comfortable with how
their data is being used
by your application.
Now, this concludes our
section on permissions.
Let's talk through other
areas in Android Q.
SVETOSLAV GANOV: Now that we're
finished with permissions,
another area we
focused our attention
was device identifiers.
In Android Q, we're locking
down hardware-based device
identifiers.
So, instead of hardware
device identifiers,
you need to use software-based,
user-resettable device
identifiers.
This is a much more
privacy-friendly solution.
We also randomize
the MAC address.
This feature shift in Android
P, as an experimental feature
under developer options, where
we use different random MAC
address when the device
connects to different networks.
Now we're bringing
this feature mainstream
available to all
apps all the time.
CHARMAINE D'SILVA:
Another area we focused on
was app launching
and notifications.
This area is important
to build user trust
that users feel like they're
in control of their device.
Apps launched into
the foreground
can sometimes feel
intrusive and disruptive
to the user experience.
Notification APIs
can be used to notify
the users without
interrupting their user flow.
There are two main benefits.
One, the users maintain context.
And two, do not disturb rules
that are actually maintained.
For cases of alarms
and incoming calls,
you can ensure a full-screen
experience when the device is
locked or heads-up notification,
like in this example, when
the device is in use.
This is why it's completely
interrupting the user.
So I will explain to you how you
can implement this in your app.
SVETOSLAV GANOV: So
the recommended way
to involve the user is
to use a notification
API you're all familiar with.
The only thing to remember is
the setFullScreenIntent API,
which allows you to
set an intent, which
will be fired off if the user is
not actively using the device.
So if the device
is locked, the user
will see a full-screen
experience.
If the user is currently
using the device,
they will see the heads-up
notifications Charmaine
mentioned.
And this will not
interrupt the user flow
while still letting the
user know there is something
requiring their attention.
CHARMAINE D'SILVA: An Android
Q background app launching
will be blocked.
Apps will no longer be
able to launch themselves
from the background
to the foreground.
This ensures that users are
appropriately interrupted
and respects their context
and do not disturb settings.
We're now on our last
leg of our journey--
foreground services.
Foreground services
are a lightweight way
to run an application when it is
not visible in the foreground.
But foreground
services can be noisy.
Try to limit your use
of foreground services
to tasks that are a continuation
of an ongoing activity,
like navigation.
SVETOSLAV GANOV: To improve the
user experience, in Android Q,
we're introducing the
concept of service types.
And we'll be limiting
permission usage
based on the service type.
For example, if your application
has while in use location
permission and you want to
use location in a foreground
service, you need to
annotate your service
as being location type.
The way you do this is using
the foreground service type
attribute in the declaration in
the manifest of your service.
And if you don't do
this, you will not
get location delivered
to your application
while this service is running.
So, we've covered a lot of
privacy features and best
practices.
And there is a lot more you can
learn on the Android Developer
website.
CHARMAINE D'SILVA: If
you want to learn more
about these features, please
attend these other privacy
sessions.
Or come talk to
us in the sandbox.
Thank you all for joining
us today and giving us
this opportunity
to work together.
Let's continue the
conversation and keep
building privacy-forward apps.
Thank you, all.
[MUSIC PLAYING]